[Applause]
[Music]
hey there everybody it has been a little
while since we have had a nice talk
about tropes archetypes recurring things
that come up in film they kind of brush
around the edges of lgbtq+
representation and this time I do mean
brush around the edges because what I'm
working on talk about today is not
explicitly about lgbtq+ characters
although I think if you talk to a lot of
lgbtq+ people particularly folks are on
my age and older there's gonna be a
decent number of them who will have at
some point in their life found
connection to the character archetype
we're gonna talk about today that is the
tomboy so before we get too far along on
this we of course need to define the
tomboy as best we can this is of course
not an academic definition this is a
working definition from looking at
examples that clearly fit the archetype
and figuring out the commonalities broad
strokes is that a tomboy is going to be
a female character who possesses a
fairly large number of traditionally
masculine traits and/or interests now
the specifics of this can run the gamut
it can be anywhere from a more masculine
sense of dress and a shorter haircut
to an interest in sports being in the
military being generally more physically
aggressive than is normally allotted to
female characters in that sort of thing
normally reserved for men being you know
a bit more rude laid-back very unrefined
those sorts of things tend to feed into
a tomboy archetype now if some of the
things that I've talked about actually
sound familiar I have kind of talked
about this before if you saw my video on
gay coding what I said in that video was
that gay coding usually starts from a
line of taking a character and imbuing
them with with traits normally
associated with the opposing gender and
for the sake of this site I trust me I
know there's more than just two genders
so when I say opposing I understand I'm
seeing if male then opposing his female
if female than the opposing his male I'm
aware of the spectrum trust me I know
but in any case that was my general
broad strokes but I did note in that
video that with female characters who
exert male characteristics that is
usually not enough on its own to gate
code them because it may simply mark
them as a tomboy now I didn't go into
tomboy is too much there but I'm going
to here and part of the reason I brought
it up there was because to feel that a
character a female kicker was properly
gay coded they really kind of had to be
paired with a another female character
who's going to serve as the prospective
love interest even if unconfirmed so
Xena and Gabrielle that's kind of your
archetypical example and if there wasn't
a probably getting with that one
additional character then it could just
be chalked up as a tomboy tomboys are
also not new they've been around for a
long long time pretty much as long as
there's been cinema and even before that
the character of Jo March from Little
Women arguably one of the archetypical
tomboys plus you know there are tons of
examples that we will get into as we go
along but those are your broad strokes a
female character who does identify as
female so this isn't a transgender thing
so with that understanding let's look at
a few examples and then we'll talk about
some commonalities and some of the
things that tend to be implied with the
way that this trope and archetype gets
used now before we get into it too far I
do want to give a special thanks to
Caroline who is one of my mods if you're
ever on my livestream and a good friend
of mine who did help me come up with
some additional examples beyond the
initial ones I thought of and she caught
some really big ones that I missed so
special things
so some of the examples that people
might be familiar with would include the
Bad News Bears both versions but I think
the original embodies it a little bit
better
we have Robocop and the partner
character there there's big hero 6 with
gogo there's hard candy and Ellen page's
character in that league of their own of
course obviously kit being the big one
but there's more than a few in there as
well
Merida in brave Rey from the last few
Star Wars movies ace from Doctor Who are
both Arya Stark and Brienne of Tarth
from game of thrones of vasquez from
aliens and honestly pretty much jodie
foster's entire acting career prior to
being in taxi driver pretty much all
fall under the tomboy archetype now if
you already know these characters you
might already know some of the things
that I'm going to point out because
there is a little bit more going on with
these than just the fact that they are
girls showing masculine interests or
tendencies as I get into some elements
of this archetype that are going to be
somewhat critical please understand this
is not a condemnation of tomboys I love
tomboy characters I love tomboys in real
life but much as when I talked about gay
coding and even the Barry your gaze
trope individual instances may be very
good but there are aspects of it as a
trend as a recurring thing that have
elements that really are all kind of
what I want to dig into
the first thing that you may have
noticed the majority of the examples I
cited and I think if you look at most
sort of lists of tomboy characters they
skew young tomboy characters more often
than not tend to be school-aged maybe
early 20s at a stretch but they skew on
the young side the impact that this has
is to imply not intentionally I would
say in the case of the vast majority of
these but the way the archetype is used
there is an implication in that pattern
that it's something that they're going
to grow out of that they're not going to
keep being this way which that somebody
has sort of been in my mind ever since
there there's a there's a Canadian comic
named Elvira Kurt one of the things she
talked about as a lesbian was that she
had a grace period growing up because
she was a tomboy and so her parents
didn't think anything about maybe her
sexuality is leaning a certain way
because it's okay for her to be a tomboy
as long as she doesn't stay that way and
eventually grows out of it and look at
that she never did
here's another thing one though the ones
that aren't notably young teens early
20s they're unmarried they're unattached
so some of the prime examples Vasquez
from aliens and yes facias is a
problematic character because the
actresses in brown face but let's that's
not the topic for this video but Vasquez
not excessively young but in the
military with no hint of an interest
sexually in any of the men around her
Brienne of Tarth who while she has her
crush on Jaime and holy crap did they
screw that up by the end she has seems
to have accepted in her life at least in
the TV show I've read the books I'm a
I'm a fake geek person but she seems to
have accepted that she is not going to
have romantic entanglements that was the
price of getting to do these other
things that she wanted to do
I mentioned the league of their own now
first of all a league of their own
actually one of my favorite movies ever
and that's big for me because I hate
sports movies but I love alia there I'll
love it to death
now kit is the tomboy character and
she's very much focused on the game on
you know the progress on getting better
her sister played by Gina Davis Dottie
she is much more feminine much less
boyish and she's married again feeding
into this notion that to be a tomboy is
not just to embrace mass traditionally
masculine things but is to miss out on
feminine things
it's actually one of the plot points
going on with the character in the
original bad news bears she worries that
her interest in sports and guy things
means that guys won't ever want to date
her because they'll see her as one of
the guys and this does on an
undercurrent get reinforced by the fact
that these characters are nearly always
unattached or there is the notion that
if they are ever going to become
attached that they need to give up some
of their more masculine leaning
independence again kind of comes up with
Joe March I'm so sick of people saying
that that love is just all a woman is
fit for I'm so sick of it I'm so lonely
so there's this recurring idea that to
choose to be a tomboy is to give up a
lot of the again traditional sort of
stereotypical defining life choices of a
woman and of course that kind of binary
is garbage and nonsense and nobody has
to give up romance or love or make up
just cuz they like to swing a bat or
would rather have a beer that a Cosmo
but that is really kind of the recurring
thing that goes on with these characters
and there's one other element that I
want to bring up and again sort of by
way of a comparison tomboys while there
are these undercurrents that have talked
about are pretty much always shouldn't
be positive characters at least all the
ones that I could come up with and think
of it's very rarely shown as a bad thing
in and of itself except where it
possibly clashes with a desire for the
more feminine things in life in addition
to that but there is a flip side to that
what about doing it the other way
what about girly boys what about sissies
what about the male characters who
exhibit an interest in the feminine well
again indicate encoding video I pointed
out there that that on its own is enough
to code them as gay without needing to
pair them with a potential partner the
way you would have to do with a female
character but more than that that is
something traditionally in life in media
is a source of mockery of ridicule of
dread of humor we as an audience in pop
culture love the tomboy and we hate the
[ __ ] and I think the reason is the same
and and I hope I don't ruin anyone's
favorite character archetype by pointing
this out but it's an undercurrent of
misogyny in both cases I do believe that
a big part of the reason why tomboys in
media and in my experience in life in
general are okay but girly boys are not
is because of the inherent underlying
still very much baked into our culture
notion that men are superior to women so
if a woman or a young girl wants to be
more like a man oh that's cute it's
aspirational she wants to better herself
but if a man shows an interest in
feminine things if a boy wants to be
more like a girl that's downgrade
that's not aspirational that is a man
choosing to be less than what he was
born to be a woman trying to be more
like a man well that's wonderful
look at the upward trajectory this is a
downward trend in the eyes of misogyny
he's choosing to be less and that is a
threat to the misogynistic concepts of
masculinity much more so than a girl
trying to be more like a boy because
that in many ways is masculinity
affirming well of course she wants to be
a little bit more like a boy boys are
the best they have it great they have it
awesome that's fine boy wants to be more
like a girl what but he has all the good
stuff he has what he's supposed to be
why would he give that up and those
questions make people uncomfortable and
it threatens the foundational assumption
that masculine is superior to feminine I
wish I had another note to sort of come
to a conclusion on but I do think that
it's worth pointing out because these
notions misogynistic patriarchal notions
are baked into our consciousness as a
society has creators as an entertainment
engaging audience these things are so
omnipresent that we don't really
lies how deep they run and that wasn't
the reason I wanted to do this video but
I knew I had to talk about that and had
to kind of build to get to that point
but this video but again I want to
stress this is not a call to stop having
tomboy characters tongue boys are
wonderful characters and they can be
great Joe March is a phenomenal
character Merida is a fantastic hair
type I don't like brave I don't think
it's a good movie but Merritt is great
gogo is a lot of fun in big hero 6 these
characters are wonderful I don't want
them to go anywhere but like so many
things we can still enjoy them but it is
important to recognize where these
things come from
where these archetypes these tropes
these characteristics why they exist in
the form that they do and I hope that
hearing my perspective on them doesn't
ruin them for you because I still enjoy
these characters and I hope you do too
but you'll be able to do so maybe with a
better possibly if I might be so bold
deeper understanding so that's it for
this one tomboys do you have a favorite
tomboy character in film TV or
literature or video games you know what
go that route that works if you do or if
you have any other thoughts you care to
share drop something on down on the
comments let's talk about it you know
the usual things you can do all of which
help me out
there's liking subscribing sharing this
around helping me out on patreon but you
also don't have to do any of it because
at the end of the day you are the
council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]